I may throw up you think well no I
actually didn't even drink that much
just two bottles but then before I came
I have three drinks hmm
hello today we're gonna talk about Edith
Wilson the first female president of the
United States Woodrow Wilson was the
president of America the United States
of America
Edith Dean Wilson was the goddamn
president's wife when her husband's at
work she's like what do I do
I gotta think it's World War one right
now so let's ration
she's like don't eat me and I'm Mondays
don't eat the gas on Sundays with the
car and then don't get an STD she said
to the soldiers wrap it up
rubbery deca so Woodrow Wilson he had 18
months left in office he s in stroke his
doctor was like Woodrow Wilson has had a
stroke
a big stroke like we can't move y'all
stroke so what you gon do and eat it was
like well who I love is this man for who
he is and who he is is the guy who wants
to be President for some good reason so
if I don't just ignore that if I don't
just ignore that if I don't help him be
President
what a kind of wife am I the doctor is
like
you gonna run the country because this
guy's out for the count
so Edith was like no problem I got this
shut up sit down I am in charge now
can I get my cheesy bread I brought your
what cheesy bread that I brought can we
finish this part what it part the part
that we want to do we're still doing it
all right I don't want the bread
mainland so eat at the wall soon she
told in America hey guys
excuse me my husband the president he's
very tired and he will be resting he's
very tired
Cindy's stressed but at this point that
Congress is like a president hasn't come
out inside in a couple of weeks
what's he doing and so they knock on the
door like excuse me
it's me Congress we're having a feeling
that I don't even know what we're
feeling but can you talk to us and she
was like no he's just super tired he has
exhaustion like don't bother him get out
of here Congress and that actually
quieted people actually quieted the
Congress and she even went to Congress
and it was like hey no big deal I'm
giving him everything you're saying
Congress I'm giving him all the letters
and the things so what do you guys think
of this rule or Allah or thing that
we're working on maybe like I should
bring it to woodrow who was like half
awake it's like alright well congress
was like blah blah and he'd be like um
she was like well I guess I'll
compromise I'm just gonna make the
decisions is doing uh make the decision
as a myself
so basically Edith Wilson was first
female president she
ran memos between Congress and him
Congress is like all right what what
what is going on so Congress picked this
one Republican senator Albert father
like Albert gonna see what's true
condition is Robeson Wilson's food
commissioners so Albert fall shows up
he's like can we come in and see the
true condition she's not stupid she's
like yeah sure come on in
so Albert fall comes in
it was I got visa this is him making
decisions every day and then I take the
thank you honey and I take the the
papers from him that I don't understand
cuz I'm just some dumb broad and eat
it's just propped up Woodrow
in bed like waving like hey and then I
go okay cool
just like bye and then they leave that's
how dumb government is we had a woman
being running this country and guess
what you could go nothing could happen
but I could go nothing bad happened 9/11
didn't happen on her watch Disney Land
with Johnny Depp at the hannam the The
Haunted Mansion this all Tim Burton that
didn't happen on her watch Christmas and
Halloween combined a lot of things
basically everyone at this point is like
where is the president where is our boss
whoever in the name of God is like our
boss is missing we can't wait to get him
back nobody nobody wants to see the boss
oh so she literally is like I can feel
the heat on me I know it Ozzie I'll set
up a photo shoot
cuz they can sense America breathing
down their neck and they propped up
Woodrow Wilson in the Oval Office
so he's like sitting there and they like
move his arm and then they just release
that to the press and that's how dumb
people were back then like oh there's
the president sitting there signing a
document what the heck are we worried
about he seems to be all at work in
school so that's all fine that's how she
ran the country
good story this is our commanders back
your head huh - good Babu yeah
they're not on the show what anything
when does it start filming and she was
like yeah I literally signed every
document I literally heard every
argument I literally wrote every piece
of paper I literally ran the country
well I wanna say one thing about her yes
ma'am
she's not a hero but that doesn't mean
she's not a hero does that understand
you complicated mm-hmm yeah thank you
[Music]